this
is the third video devoted to my caption
contest that i do on my youtube channel
so if you're interested
in participating in it and you're a
subscriber but you don't have
notifications on
you probably want to turn those on this
third caption contest turned out even
better than the
previous two and i selected for it this
this picture that i took a while back
when i was down on my family land
in northwestern indiana just north of
rose lawn
and my family has had fields for
quite a while which we let out to some
local farmers
and this year they were planting corn
you can see that the corn is quite high
that year it was a pretty good year
as far as yield goes and
while i was living there and actually
during all the summers and times that i
spent there i would often walk
out in the fields because it was good
exercise and i like being out there and
being surrounded
by all this uh this nature and so i
wrote here in the new caption contest
i'll take the 10
best ones totally subjective decided by
me of course
and put them into the next video which
you're watching right now
this is from my family's land when i was
there for a visit and took a walk along
the fields so as
you can well predict there were a lot
of comments that were puns and you can
see
a roundup of them here most of them
corn related puns i guess there's kind
of a meta
level there because you can talk about
things being corny
and also make a pun at the same time
retro gamer had a good one there
twisting in a somewhat different way
looking into greg's channel
you would certainly appreciate the
cornucopia
and josh had a good one there as well
when your students attention wanders and
you need an
audience that is all ears
then there were some other references
that i've also
aggregated here that had to do with
movies and i should have predicted this
ahead of time that there'd be a lot of
children of the corn references if you
don't know the children of the corn it
was a horror movie
the first one i think was in the mid-80s
and it spun off a set of worse and worse
horror movies following after that so
alfonso says gregory sadler's been
declared the next director to
helm the new lions gate reboot of
children of the corn filming a slater to
commence in march
uh ethie writes that's what you get when
you cross socrates with children of the
corn
lonnie says children of the corn ex
nietzsche's child comes to life
but then there were two other movies
that were being referenced
and one of them i kind of figured i
would get
so you see down on the bottom if you
think it they will be
and then back to the fields of childhood
dreams obviously
you know field of dreams the kevin
costner
film where he builds a baseball
stadium and i don't really remember all
that much other than ghosts
coming to play a baseball game there and
i think everybody's like you know
fixed by the end of the movie but then
retro gamer
also says when you try to time your
reenactment of a scene from north by
northwest to get the right shot
but after six hours there's no sign of a
crop duster
so i haven't seen that movie for a long
time but i i think i remember the scene
that he's talking about
so let's get to the 10 best of the
quips now that those are out of the way
here's a good one by pramita when you
finally come out of the allegory of the
cave
and see the light yeah it was a blazing
day and cornfields are usually fairly
humid so you know
if we did have an allegory of the cave
and it was set in indiana
you'd be looking at corn or soy uh most
likely once you came out of the
the cave here's another really good one
by naomi
anyone who visits with who's hoosiers
should take care that he does not in the
process become a hoosier
and if you gaze too long into a
cornfield the cornfield
gazes back into you okay so that's
obviously a you know
parody of a nietzsche quote about you
know
not gazing into the abyss and about
monsters
and you know i'm not myself a hoosier
but i
i suppose i'm sort of an honorary
hoosier since i've spent so much
time there this one's a little bit
shorter
a little bit more self-explanatory
perhaps by gloth
phenomenology of spirit midwest edition
and you know indiana isn't the only
place where they grow corn you can think
of you know lots of parts of wisconsin
and illinois
and iowa uh michigan
even going into ohio and
yeah the midwest is is full of this this
sort of stuff if you just look around
well i'll say as a sort of side note
when i've lived in other areas it's been
very interesting to see
what other crops they grow like down
down south i'd never seen a cotton field
before and that was quite interesting
another thing they have in indiana are
mint fields
just you know mint as far as you can see
and then there's all sorts of other
things as well
here's another good one when the
existential crisis hits and you just
need to walk around
in some corn kind of like that one
i actually did spend quite a bit of time
walking around
those particular corn fields you don't
walk around in them
of course you walk around the fields on
the paths i guess you could
go into the corn if you wanted to
but it's it's not all that often done
so um here's another one by
isabel as he contemplated the vast field
of corn professor sadler once again
resolved to understand the balance sheet
of his own
life that's a good one there's something
about
looking over it could be corn could be
barley could be
wheat could be rye could be you know
vegetable
fields could be soy although soy is kind
of short you know
uh those plants don't grow that high
there's something about
going out into the fields especially
when if you go to like the fields for uh
flower places and you just see like tons
and tons of zinnias or marigolds
it's it's pretty cool to do that and it
does lend a certain kind of perspective
all right uh victor de leon uh he who
philosophy
philosophizes behind the rose
uh kind of an interesting little quip
there
you know um tying in with the other ones
and now we get into some of the the
funnier
ones that are that are not particularly
puns
but they're they're pretty good uh
jeremy says the face you make when you
realize
life did not give you lemons but
presumably he gave you corn
instead uh yeah and you know you can
tell i'm smiling there i enjoy
being out there um juan's as i want to
believe
you know if you don't know what that's a
reference to
[Music]
google the x-files and they spent quite
a bit of time
out in places like that
uh in in the show and mulder
might have been from like a country
background i don't quite remember
here's one playing off of all those
lousy t-shirts things i left wisconsin
and all i got was this
stupid corn field i mean obviously you
could get corn fields here
in wisconsin but they wouldn't be
growing quite as high most likely
and then finally last and least this is
a great one by austin
when your mom makes you take that
obligatory photo at the county fair
shortly before abandoning you in the
corn maze
so she can get smashed on three dollar
hard
ciders yeah i mean i'll tell you what
that that area of indiana newton county
you ought to go to the newton county
fair and you will see some people like
that
there the fair brings out all the people
who you don't ordinarily
cross paths with and
you know corn mazes are a big thing down
there not just for the fair
but for halloween and all sorts of other
time of the year sort of sort of things
as well so that's a that's a good joke
i'll be doing more of these caption
contests in the future so if you want to
get in
on them uh just you know stay tuned if
you're not if you don't have the
little bell thing clicked on my channel
you might want to do that so that you
get notifications
of it and you can get in on these
contests
so that's it for this one
you